Архітектура Полтави
підпорядковується ландшафту.
Природа все-таки домінує
в морфології міста.
І це є однією з головних
його особливостей.
Спочатку воно було невеликою фортецею
з окремими селами, які знаходилися навколо.
Потім з XIX століття місто розвивається,
фортечні вали зрівнюються,
перетворюються на вулиці, бульвари,
і місто розширюється.
Відповідно, змінюється архітектура.
Якщо в XVII столітті місто
було повністю дерев'яним,
то вже в XIX столітті місто
переважно кам'яне.
Новий етап архітектури Полтави розпочався
лише на початку ХХ століття,
з появою українського модерну.
Будівля Полтавського краєзнавчого музею,
що первісно називалась
будівлею губернського земства,
взагалі, є унікальною не тільки тому,
що це перший і дуже вдалий зразок
українського модерну,
але й тому, що він з'явився
не те, щоб випадково,
але ніхто не очікував,
що він з'явиться саме так.
1903 року, коли в Полтаві відкрили
пам'ятник Котляревському,
якраз була нагода, і сюди з'їхалася
вся українська інтелігенція:
і з тієї частини України,
яка знаходилася в Російській імперії,
і з тієї частини,
яка була в Австро-Угорській імперії.
Тобто там були і Леся Українка, і Коцюбинський,
і Олена Пчілка, Старицький —
всі-всі, хто тільки можна.
Якраз на відкриття цього пам'ятника була
зроблена виставка конкурсних проєктів
на доробку цієї будівлі,
на добудову її фактично.
На цьому конкурсі переміг проєкт
художника Василя Кричевського,
який, власне, був протеже
художника Сергія Васильківського,
який був одним із ініціаторів конкурсу,
і він намагався потім
всіляко допомогти Кричевському.
Багато фахівців не знали,
як взагалі класифікувати,
як сказати про цю будівлю.
Казали, що це і німецька,
і східна архітектура, і Сластіон.
В офіційному найавторитетнішому журналі
того часу в Російській імперії написали,
що це саме український стиль.
Звідси й походить наш український модерн.
Одразу впадає нам у вічі
величезна кількість орнаментів,
які тут розміщені.
Василь Григорович був
не лише архітектором —
він їздив в експедиції по Полтавщині, Київщині,
Харківщині, його рідній Сумщині
і збирав всюди, де бачив,
ці зразки орнаментів.
І потім адаптував їх до стін будівлі.
А провідний сюжет,
який ми тут можемо побачити,
і його величезна кількість варіацій —
це дерево життя.
Якщо ви поглянете на верхній фриз,
то там його різні варіанти,
що майже не повторюються.
Це все завдяки Василю Григоровичу,
який об'їздив всі ці різні села і міста
і зібрав ці орнаменти.
Куди? Туди, так?
Запрошую вас далі в історичні відділи.
Я стараюся, щоб вам можна було
і наш музей гарно показати,
ну і я щоб така прикольна була.
Так, рухаємося далі.
Зали, присвячені...
О Боже, вибачте.
Перепрошую.
Зали, присвячені історії Полтавщини
періоду ХІХ-початку ХХ століття,
так званого періоду Полтавської губернії.
Пара волів української сірої породи.
Зараз таких волів, таких корів
майже не збереглося.
А чумаки їх дуже цінували.
Тому що уявіть, оці велетенські
тварини могли перевозити вагу
від 800 кг до майже двох тонн.
Якщо чумакування вдавалося,
тобто чумак був заможним,
то він роги визолочував.
Якщо чумак гинув у дорозі,
то роги волові мазали дьогтем
як символ трауру.
А якщо віл був переможцем у боях,
захищав свою валку,
то йому на роги в'язали
червону стрічку.
Тобто теж такі ось різноманітні цікавинки.
Полтавська губернія була заснована
1802 року у складі 15 повітів.
І до речі, саме герби цих повітів
і знаходяться на фасаді нашого будинку.
Василь Григорович спеціально
їх там розмістив для того,
щоб підкреслити, які саме
повіти входили до складу губернії,
а також щоб показати,
що будинок може бути
літописом у камені.
І саме ці герби символізують
полкові міста, полки,
які завжди стояли на обороні
нашої батьківщини,
завжди боронили свої землі.
На сьогодні у фондах закладу
нараховується близько 300 тисяч предметів.
Величезна кількість відділів,
загалом 150 людей працює в музеї.
Кожен відділ займається
різними експедиціями:
відділ етнографії
відправляється в етнорозвідки,
відділ археології —
в археологічні експедиції,
відділ пам'яткознавства займається вивченням
і описом об'єктів пам'яткоохоронної діяльності.
Тобто кожен відділ,
мандруючи Полтавщиною,
здобуває собі конкретно
цільові направлені предмети.
Однак Полтавщина
історично набагато більша.
Це територія частково сучасних Сумщини,
Харківщини, Київщини, Черкащини.
Тобто можемо приймати
предмети і навіть із цих регіонів,
вони теж будуть типовими для нас.
Вам тут світло потрібне?
Бо в нас тут одна лампа так гуде, що...
Ми зараз будуємо експозицію:
«Полтавщина у 30-х роках ХХ століття.
Голодомор-геноцид 1932-33 років і політичні репресії».
Показуючи Голодомор,
ми йшли шляхом не показувати прямо смерті,
людей, які лежать на вулицях,
а вирішили образно через цих людей,
які ховають Василя у фільмі «Земля».
І от на цьому похороні ці люди
стікаються, стікаються з оцих вулиць,
і виходить отакий великий
масив цих людей, українців.
І вибрали слова Бориса Олійника:
«Коли вмирає одна людина —
з нею умирає світ.
Коли мільйони йдуть у прірву —
тоді вмирає вже ціла галактика».
Ці репресії торкалися
багатьох родин, багатьох сімей.
І звичайно, ми маємо право говорити
про постгеноцидне суспільство,
тому що, як наголошував Джеймс Мейс,
можливо, деякі проблеми
українського суспільства саме від того,
що Україна пережила
Голодомор-геноцид 1932-33 років.
І дійсно, коли дивишся,
як все це вирішувалось,
як ліквідовувалось українство,
то, я думаю, що це урок.
Урок для всіх нас,
для всіх українців.
Нам просто треба знати свою історію.
Під час окупації німцями Полтави 1941 року
вони тут дуже добре хазяйнували.
І якщо до війни колекція музею нараховувала
більше 117 тисяч предметів,
то після війни залишилося
ледь більше 39 тисяч.
Будівля теж була понівечена.
Коли 1943 року окупанти відступали,
то вони її обливали
спеціальним розчином і підпалили.
Залишилися тільки голі стіни фактично.
Все, що було всередині, було знищено.
На згарищі потім співробітники музею
збирали предмети, які залишилися,
і до цього часу в нашій колекції є група,
яку ми називаємо «Горілий фонд».
Так-от, наші реставратори займаються відновленням
і поверненням до життя цих предметів.
Ми не виготовляємо нові речі,
ми не намагаємося зробити річ новою.
Ми залишаємо і зберігаємо її історію,
але робимо її доступною
і зрозумілою для відвідувача.
Реставрація одного предмету триває
від одного до трьох місяців.
Звичайно, ми синхронно працюємо
над кількома предметами,
бо деякі процеси досить тривалі,
потребують і замочування,
і накладання компресів на певний час.
Процес доволі творчий,
часто залежить
і від настрою, і від натхнення,
особливо коли це доповнення малюнків.
Часто нам доволиться вивчати і технології,
за якими виготовлялися,
звертатися до гончарних інструментів для того,
щоб мати можливість
повторити отой неповторний малюнок,
прийнамні наблизитись до тієї якості
і того мистецького значення.
Найважче стриматись і не спробувати
повернути до життя те,
що за нашими вимогами
повертатись до життя не може.
Є таке правило:
предмет, який зруйнований більш ніж на 30%,
назад до життя вже не повертається.
Він має наукове значення,
але його не можна догіпсувати
більш ніж на половину.
Але іноді предмети дуже гарні,
іноді цього дуже хочеться,
дуже хочеться зробити лялечку,
але не можна.
Для мене особисто це — найважче.
На головному фасаді будівлі
ми можемо бачити,
що на першому поверсі вікна
мають напівкруглу арку-завершення.
Це вікна якраз попереднього проєкту,
які були вже зведені на момент,
коли оголосили конкурс.
І для того, щоб їх органічно включити в цю
структуру майбутнього українського модерну,
навколо них зроблено
шестикутні обрамлення для того,
щоб вони не вибивалися
із загального сприйняття.
У первісному проєкті вікна мали
шестикутні зірки у фронтонах,
ну не у фронтонах, у вікнах,
але, знову ж таки, такі шестикутні зірки
активно використовувалися
в культовій українській
архітектурі як орнамент,
а вже під час відновлення будівлі
наприкінці 1940-х- на початку 1950-х —
її доволі довго відновлювали —
замінили зірки на п'ятикутні,
щоб ідеологічно бути ближче.
Тому що ця будівля
не подобалася ні Миколі ІІ,
який приїжджав в Полтаву
і казав, що це дуже «врєдноє зданіє»,
типу піднімає українську свідомість.
Так само, наскільки ми розуміємо,
і радянській владі теж не дуже
сподобалася ідея відновлення цієї будівлі.
Вона була спалена,
тобто всередині все вигоріло,
але зовнішні стіни повністю вціліли,
зокрема й більшість кераміки вціліла.
Але, тим не менше,
все-таки вдалося її відновити,
щоправда зробивши ці п'ятикутні зірки
і червоний черепичний дах,
з чисто червоної черепиці,
щоб це була будівля,
яка вписувалася би
в тодішню комуністичну ідеологію.
Все керамічне оздоблення головного фасаду
виготовлене було опішнянськими майстрами.
Це опішнянська характерна кераміка,
з типовими сюжетами «дерево життя»,
різноманітними орнаментами,
які, власне, використовувались
на Полтавщині.
Якраз оцей ґанок оздоблювався
майстрами-кустарями,
які не те що не мали освіти,
вони виготовляли кераміку просто,
як вони її розуміли.
Кричевський наполягав саме на тому,
щоб тут має бути жива,
народна кераміка,
яка не має ознак якоїсь школи, освіти.
Це дещо схоже на те,
як свого часу в Британії Вільям Морріс
по суті відродив народні ремесла,
заснувавши рух
«Мистецтво та ремесло».
Тобто в такий спосіб він відроджував це
в Британії в другій половині ХІХ століття,
а Василь Кричевський, київський Сластіон і вся ця компанія
почали робити це в Україні на початку ХХ століття.
Краєзнавчий музей — це моя домівка,
бо фактично ми тут проводимо вісім
годин робочого дня, а то й більше.
І я щоранку, коли йду на роботу,
і музей вигулькує з-за дерев парку,
чесно, я посміхаюся, я радію,
що йду в такий чудовий заклад.
Я не кривлю душею,
я його дуже люблю.
Для мене це домівка,
сім'я і це можливість росту.
Музеї сьогодні — це місця пам'яті.
Чим більше людей познайомиться
з предметами старовини,
чим більше людей зрозуміє глибину
нашої української історії,
тим краще буде, тим паче наша нація
підійметься над собою,
буде розуміти свою історію.